ف منن امن وعمل صالحا فله
جزاء الحسنى وسنقول له بامرنا يسرى ثم
اتبع سببا حتى اذا بلغ فطلع الشمس فها
تضرع على لم نجعل لهم من شروطها سترا كذلك
وقد احطنا بما لديه را
ثم اعس
حتى اذا بلغ بين السنين وجل ما ق لا يجون
يفون خدا قالوا يا ذا القرنين ان ياجوج
وماجوج يفسدون في ول نجعل على ان تجعل بين
سدا قال ما نكني في ربي خير فاعينوني بقوه
اجعل بينكم وبينكم ونا ت
حتى اذا ساوى بين الصفين
قال حتى اذا جعلنا و
قالم عليه را فاستطاعوا ان يقروا وما
استطاعوا له نقبا قال هذا
رحمه من قي فاذا
جاء وعم رب
جعله
دكا وكان وعد ربي حقا وتركنا بعضهم
يومئذ يموج في ب ونبق في الصوح
فجمعناهم جمعا وعرضنا جهنم ي للكافرين عر
الذين كانت عينهم في
قضائ ذكري وكان
افحسب الذين كفروا ان يتخذوا عبادي من
دوني
اولياء انا اعتدنا جهنم للكافرين نسلا قل
هل ننبئكم
بالرين اعمالنا والذين ظل سعيهم في الحياه
يسب
ائك الذين كفروا بايات ربهم
ولقائه فحبطت
اعمالهم فحبطت اعمالهم فلا نقيم لكم يوم
القيامه
وسنا ذلك
جزا
جهنم بما كفروا واتخذوا اياتي وخصني
وزورا ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
كانت لهم جن
الفردوس الى خالدين فيها لا يذرون عنها ج
قل لو كان البحر مذاد ل كلمات ربي لنفذ
البحر لنفذ البحر قبل ان
تنفد كلمات ربي ولو جنا بثه
مددا انما انا
بشر منكم يوحى الي انما
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
الله لا اله
الا
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول الله
اشهد
ان
محمد رسول
[Silence]
الله حي على الصلاه
حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الفلاح حي على
الفلاح
[Silence]
ا
الله اكبر الله
الله
اكبر
لا اله
الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستهديه
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد ومن يضلل
فلن تجد له وليا
مرشدا واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم
صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
والتابعين اما بعد معاشر الموحدين عباد
الله فان اصدق الكلام كلام الله عز وجل
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وان شر الامور محدثاتها وان كل محدثه بدعه
وان كل بدعه ضلاله وان كل ضلاله في
النار يقول الله سبحانه
وتعالى يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي
خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث
منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا ويقول
سبحانه
وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم مس
مسلمون ويقول سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين
امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا قولا سديدا يصلح
لكم اعمالكم ويغفر لكم
ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما اما
بعد
اليوم على كثره المواضيع التي ممكن ان
نتحدث بها
وجدت ان اكثر المواضيع استهلاكا
واستنزاف عند الائمه هو الحديث عن يوم
الجمعه وفضائله
واهميته لنا
كمسلمين وهذا معلوم ولا يحتاج
تفصيل الا انني ايضا وجدت عند الناس
اليوم فهم مغلوط عن منبر يوم الجمعه وخطبه
الجمعه
تحديدا و وما المتوقع منك كمسلم مستمع
للامام وما المتوقع من الخطيب الذي يخطب
[Silence]
العه
خطبه
جمعه خطبه الجمعه واهميتها في الاسلام لدى
المسلمين قلنا لا شك ان الجمعه لها اهميه
وافضل فهي من افضل الايام واعظمها وهذا
معلوم بين المسلمين والحديث فيه
مستهلك لكن لا بئس لا باس في التكرار
والاعاده جعل الله سبحانه وتعالى خطبه
وصلاه الجمعه فرضا على كل رجل قادر وجعل
الحضور لها والانصات للخطيب فرضا كما هو
معلوم من صريح الايه
الكريمه يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا نودي
للصلاه من يوم الجمعه فاسعوا الى ذكر
الله فاسعوا الى ذكر الله وذروا البيئ
ذلكم خير لكم ان كنتم
تعلمون يقول المفسرون ان ذكر الله في
الايه هو سماع الخطبه وليس
الصلاه الخطبه التي تشهدها الملائكه
والدليل من حديث ابي هريره رضي الله عنه
ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم قال من
اغتسل يوم الجمعه ثم راح في الساعه الاولى
فكانما قرب بدنه وهو
الجمل ومن راح في الساعه الثانيه فكانما
قرب بقره وقال من راح في الثالثه فكانما
قرب قرب كبشا ومن راح في الساعه الرابعه
فكانما قرب دجاجه وفي الخامسه فكانما قرب
بيضا فاذا خرج الامام وهنا الشاهد قال
حضرت الملائكه يستمعون
الذكر فاسعوا الى ذكر الله
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى خط
صلاه
ران الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
الىر الله
حديث هريره رضي الله عنه صلى الله عليه
وسلم
‏said second
hour saf aowd hour like
sheep
hour
ence خ
خ
[Silence]
ولما كان من هديه صلى الله عليه وسلم كما
يقول ابن القيم ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يخطب كل وقت بما تقتضيه حاجه الناس
ومصلحتهم فالخطب امر عظيم استقر في قلوب
الصحابه والتهيئه له من اكبر الدلائل
التهيئه ليوم الجمعه والصلاه والخطبه من
اكبر
الدلائل على اهميتها
امر الشرع بالاغتسال
والتبكير والتطيب
والاحتشاد والاقتراب والانصات وكانه
الاستعداد لاجل الامور
واعظمها صلى الله عليه
وسلمن الق
عليه وسلح
[Silence]
علس where and do do
this you are
ت اجر
خطبه ومن تصحيح المفاهيم ابتداء دعنا نبدا
بالمقدمه التي تسمعها من افواه الخطباء
مرارا وتكرارا كل يوم جمعه هذه الصيغه
الافتتاحيه التي تسمعها كلكل كل جمعه هي
ليست كلمات تقليديه يرددها الخطباء انما
هي من هدي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هذه
المقدمه هي من وصف ما كان يتقدم و يبتدئ
به النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ويبدا
الخطب
خطيبج ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
برافت صلى الله عليه
وسلم اقرا في وصف الخطب للنبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم تجد الخطباء اليوم منهم من يعلو
صوته ويحمر و وجهه وعيناه ويعلو
صوته
ويتعرق وجهه وحق لهم ذلك فخطبت الجمعه هي
نداء استيقاظ لك يا
مسلم هي نداء استيقاظ و وسيله لتحريك
الهمم واستفزاز النفحات الايمانيه في قلب
كل
مسلم لما وصل جابر رضي الله عنه حال النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم اثناء الخطبه قال كان
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اذا خطب احمرت
عيناه وعلى صوته واشتد غضبه حتى كانه منذر
جيش حتى كانه منذر جيش يقول صبحك
ومساكم ثم يقول اما بعد فان خير الحديث
كتاب الله وخير الهدي وخير الهدي هدي محمد
وشر الامور محدثاتها وكل بدعه
ضلاله خطب صلى الله عليه
وسلم جابر الله
‏prop صل علسلم خب say whenever prop صل
عليه
وسلم خطب his
eyes his be
loud and his anger is visible his face
and it's not not
personal he gets emotional as he trying
to deliver the because he know it's a
wake call for muslim
منبر الجمعه لا يعلمك الصلاه والصوم
والزكاه فحسب هذه اركان لابد لك ان تعلمها
ولها حلقاتها العلميه حلقاتها العلميه
منبر الجمعه ليس للامتاع منبر الجمعه يجب
ان يق يوقظ فيك التفكير والشعور الايماني
النائم طيله ايام
الاسبوع منبر الجمعه يجب ان يستفز حالتك
الايمانيه منبر الجمعه يجب ان يشحن همتك
وعزيمتك منبر الجمعه يجب ان لا يجامل وان
لا يكون على
هواك كلام المنبر يجب ان يجعلك تخرج مسرعا
لخير تلتمس كلام المنبر يجب ان ان يخرجك
من المسجد مسرعا لمسكين تحسن اليه او
والده او زوجه تترفق بحالها
كلام المنبر يجب ان يحفزك على القران
ودروس
العلم منبر الجمعه يعلمك الاهتمام لامور
وقضايا المسلمين ويحرض فيك
اسلامك بحيث يحثك على النصره
والمعاون صلاه زكاه
[Silence]
‏more
‏from
[Silence]
انعفس اليوم الناس في في الاموال والابناء
والتجاره طيله ايام
الاسبوع لذلك كان لابد من المفروض بل من
المفروض شرعا عليك ان تحضر الجمعه وان
تسمع للخطيب بانصات وتمعن لانه هو المنبر
الاجتماعي والديني والسياسي الذي يعرض
عليك ما تقتضيه الحاجه يقول العلماء ان
يوم الجمعه وفي خطبه
الجمعه يكاد يكون الناس على اربعه احوال
فالاول فانه
يعلم
ويعمل يعلم كلام الخطيب ويعمل به فهنيئا
له ونسال الله له نسال الله له الثبات اما
الثاني فانه يعلم ونسي
فيخرج بالتذكره على
القليل واما الثالث فانه لا يعلم ولا يعمل
فيخرج بالعلم واما الاخير فانه يعلم ولكنه
كسل
فينشط مجد
[Silence]
اللهب the does not know who knows does
not do
[Silence]
‏given
it andd does not
andes he does not because does not he
didn't
know so he leaves a frid at least
[Silence]
بارك الله لي ولكم في القران العظيم
ونفعني واياكم بهدي سيد المرسلين اقول ما
تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم فاستغفروه
انه الغفور الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على المبعوث رحمه
للعالمين اللهم صل على محمد واله واصحابه
اجمعين اللهم وارضى عنا وعنهم
اجمعين عن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه ان رسول
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ذكر يوم يوم الجمعه فقال فيه ساعه لا
يوافقها عبد مسلم وهو قائم
يصلي يسال الله شيئا الا اعطاه
اياه صلى الله عليه
وسلم ابو هريره رضي الله عنه
الله
اللهه
قائم different opinions
on the of
frid
دعا دعا الله سبحانه
وتالى حث
الله and
before
fin
ask
حن the hospital as we and he trav to her
so make them and keep them in your ان
شاء الله الله جفم شفاه ان عافيه وسائر
مرضى المسلمين اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا
محمد في الاولين وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد
في الاخرين وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في كل
وقت
وحين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد
حتى ترث الارض ومن عليها وانت خير
الوارثين اللهم انت احق من ذكر واحق من
عبد عبد واكرم من ابتغي واراف من ملك
واجود من سئل واوسع من اعطى انت الملك لا
شريك لك والفرد لا ند لك كل شيء كل شيء
هالك الا وجهك لن تطاع الا باذنك ولن تعصى
الا بعلمك اقرب شهيد وادنى حفيظ القلوب لك
مفضيه والسر عندك علانيه الحلال ما احللت
والحرام ما حرمت والدين ما شرت والامر ما
قضيت والخلق خلقك والعبد عبدك وانت الله
الرؤوف الرحيم اللهم نسالك بكل حق هو لك
وبحق السائلين عليك ان تقبلنا في هذا
اليوم المبارك وان تجيرنا من النار برحمتك
يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم كل لاخواننا المستضافين في
كل مكان كن لهم وليا ونصيرا اللهم اشدد
وطك على المجرمين ومن عاونهم واشدد وطك
على الغاصبين المعتدين واشدد وطك على
الظالمين اعدائك اعداء الدين وا واشتد بطك
على قتله الاطفال والرجال
والمسنين اللهم اجعلهم في ضمانك ادخلهم في
امانك وابني عليهم سور حمايتك وادفع عنهم
مدافع اللهم احفظنا واحفظهم بما تحفظ به
اوليائك اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلم وعل
رايتي الحق والدين
المبين اللهم تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا انك انت التواب الرحيم
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه والتابعين اللهم احينا على
سنته وامتنا على ملته واوردنا حوضه واكتب
لنا شفاعته يا رب العالمين اللهم اجز
سيدنا محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم عنا خير ما
جزيت به نبيا عن امته اللهم اجزي عنا
سيدنا محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم خير ما
جزيت نبيا عن امته عباد الله ان الله يامر
بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى
عن الفحشاء والمنكر
والبغي يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب رب
العالمين واقيم
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله استقيم اعتدل استو سو صف سد الخلل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
والقمر والليل اذ ادبر والصبح
اذا اسفر
انها لاحدى الكبر نذيرا
للبشر لمن
شاء منكم ان يتقدم او
يتاخر كل
نفس بما كسبت
هينه الا اصحاب
اليمين في
جنات
يتساءلون
يتساءلون عن
المجرمين ما سلككم في سقر قالوا لم نك من
المصلين ولم نكن نطعم
المسكين
وكننا نخوض مع
الخائضين
وكنا نكذب بيوم
الدين
حتى اتانا
اليقين فما
تنفعهم شفاعه الش
فعين الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امينين
ارايت الذي يكذب
بالدين فذلك الذي يدع
اليتيم ولا يحض على طعام
المسكين فويل
للمصلين الذين هم عن صلاتهم
ساهون الذين هم
يراءون
ويمنعون
الماعون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
الله شده